hello everyone welcome to the 2023
holiday message from the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll every
year we do this holiday message because
basically I take roughly two weeks off
for holiday time so next week really
will take off there will be no uh
mindscape podcast released on Christmas
Day itself but the previous week we do
the holiday message which is supposed to
be a short shorter than usual anyway
little solo podast
not quite a full-blown podcast not
something it deserves to be a solo
episode all by itself but a little brief
reflection on something interesting that
is either on my mind at the moment or
happened during the year or many things
happen during the year or whatever it
happens to be so this year I thought
that there was something interesting
that I participated in this year back in
September I was a speaker at a workshop
at the Santa Fe Institute devoted to the
topic of immortality it yes you heard
that correctly immortality living
forever this was the topic and I love
this fact about the Santa Fe Institute
that they're willing to be that
adventurous I guess maybe is the word to
try something different extraordinarily
interdisciplinary so this is an idea
that was actually hatched by David
crackower previous mindscape guest and
Caitlyn McShay who is also at SFI and
they brought together a bunch of people
uh scientists but also literary artist
type people um people from a variety of
different Humanities as well as social
sciences and physical sciences
backgrounds and just said yeah
immortality let's talk about it what
what does it mean what are the prospects
would it be good or bad Etc uh very
specifically it was not about mortality
mortality dying is something that we
don't want to face up to but okay we do
talk talk about the prospect of it and
it's very important to and as I've said
several times I don't think we do a very
good job in our culture right now but
immortality we don't talk about that
much probably because it's not very
realistic to be frank but would it be a
good idea if we could do it how close
can we come to doing it and that those
were the kinds of things that got talked
about at the workshop so very little of
the workshop actually in retrospect was
literally about immortality you know
immortality is one of those words that
carries implications of the infinite
living literally forever most of the
people who Rose to the occasion to give
talks uh including a few uh previous
mindscape guests like Jeffrey West
talked about longevity longevity of
individuals of ideas of cities and and
so forth my job was to bring the cosmic
perspective here and to kind of be a
Down
to say that even in Principle as far as
we understand the universe right now
true immortality is really not quite
possible maybe the universe can be
Eternal and infinite but what we think
of as human mortality can't so but it
was a wonderful Workshop overall it was
very stimulating people coming from
completely different angles on this
question really thinking it through even
though it sounds a little silly at first
glance it's important to face up to what
uh one of my old philosophy professors
called limit Concepts you know push
yourself to the limit of what you're
comfortable thinking about or
contemplating and look at what you learn
look at what you bring back what does
this tell you about yourself and your
more realistic concerns here in the
world so that's what we're going to do
here in this particular holiday message
so let's
go
the first question to confront when
you're told to think about immortality
is what does that mean what is the
definition of immortality and you might
say I I know what that is it's easy it's
living forever that's what it means to
be immortal but okay what do you mean by
living in other words some people at the
workshop raised the issue that if the
universe is eternal and you have some
version and we have to be careful about
what we mean by some version of lassus
demon going on then in some sense you'll
live forever if there's a famous example
that physicists always use when they
talk about the black hole information
loss Paradox right they say look if you
have a book and you throw it into a fire
and the book Burns then the information
that was in the book is lost in practice
to you you don't know what the book says
anymore but in principle if all the laws
of physics are being obeyed then the
specific ways in which the book burned
are implicated in the specific kind of
heat and light and Ashes that were
produced by that fire so if you had
infinite capacity to figure out what all
that information was and also to
reconstruct it Etc you could read what
was in the book this is of course
exactly what lass's demon would have to
do the hypothetical vast intelligence
proposed by Pierre Simone llas that
could know the position and velocity of
every particle in a classical universe
and use that to completely know both the
past and the future there's some
complications here depending on your
favorite version of quantum mechanics
Etc but the point remains that in some
sense modern physics thinks that the
information contained in you persists
Through Time
this doesn't count as immortality that
is my first message we talked about this
I think most people actually agree with
me on this one but trying to get exactly
straight what it does mean so you know
what does it mean to say that you have
died I mean the information that is in
your brain Etc is still contained in the
universe so what exactly happens and if
you really dig into it I would
definitely be someone who argued that
you at this moment is not exactly the
same person as you 5 minutes ago much
less 5 years ago we change over time so
if on the one hand we're always changing
over time inevitably and on the other
hand the information contained within us
in principle persists out there in the
universe then either we live for just a
moment or for forever right of course
the reconciliation to all this silliness
is to admit that we are talking about
the macroscopic world we're talking
about an emergent level of reality when
we talk about people and their lives and
deaths so in fact what happens is
forgetting about lass's demon and
microscopic
information various parts of the
universe come together to give rise to
you a person and we call that being born
or being conceived or whatever moment
you want to attach to the first moment
when you were really being you and then
you live your life and over the course
of living your life there is accessible
information about you by accessible I
mean we're not being lus demon we're not
pretending to know where every single
molecule in your body is but maybe I can
know roughly where you're located how
tall you are what your hair color is I
can talk to you about your wants and
needs and things like that that's the
accessible information that defines who
you are as a macroscopic person and over
the course of your lifetime that
accessible information comes and goes
goes and then once you reach death at
least in the current way that it's
understood at our current moment of
technological progress that information
about who you were your hopes and dreams
Etc is no longer accessible from you
right it's no longer accessible from
your body maybe you wrote it down in a
diary or something but we don't count
that as you we don't count that as being
Immortal so I think that as long as we
understand this sort of macroscopic
emerging perspective it makes sense to
say that real human beings have some
kind of finite
lifespan I think it's also very
important here to imagine that these
real human beings we're talking about
have a kind of finite memory right like
there's some psychological continuity it
is not absolute we do not remember
everything that happened to us but it is
not absent either if we did remember
nothing about what happen to us from
moment to moment in time then this
notion of individual identity and
psychological continuity over time
wouldn't be that useful right so I think
that as long as we have this macroscopic
perspective and we admit that even
though we change over time we don't
change utterly over time we keep some
information some memory some common
characteristics of who we are from
moment to moment I think is perfectly
well defined to say that people have a
lifespan and as far as we know that
lifespan is not infinite now some of you
will know there is a possible Loop
loophole here in the case of the many
world's interpretation of quantum
mechanics right famously there's this
idea of quantum immortality Max tegar
and other previous guests and others
have talked about Quantum immortality
and there's different ways to play this
game but roughly speaking the idea is
that you are this collection of atoms
and other expectations of Elementary
fields that make up the universe you
obey the rules of quantum mechanics
let's say and let's say that we believe
in the many worlds interpretation of
quantum mechanics then different things
happen to us so on different branches we
might uh act in slightly different ways
we might respond to other kinds of
branching events where Quantum
measurements are made Geer counters
Universe splitter apps on our iPhones or
what have you so we are slightly
different people uh descended from us on
all these different branches of the wave
function and either you can play this
game different ways like I said but you
can either bring this about by some
Quantum random number generator hooked
up to a device that will kill you or
just by letting time evolve and seeing
what happens one way or the other you
can argue that there will always be one
branch of the wave function on which you
remain alive indefinitely long even if
in the overwhelming majority of branches
of the wave functions you will die there
might be one branch in which you live
forever
essentially now I don't think that this
is is a very Illuminating uh thought
experiment personally I I think that the
technical parts of it are all plausibly
correct as far as we know uh we don't
specifically know how many branches of
the wave function there are if there's a
finite number that changes things from
an infinite number and so forth but
let's Grant all of the assumptions of
the thought experiment and imagine that
somewhere out there in the many branches
of the wave function of the universe you
do live forever there is some kind of
quantum immortality then longtime
listeners will know that going to say I
don't care about that for mostly for the
reason that if you want to care if you
want to believe in many worlds at all
okay if you want to accept that as the
correct theory of the world in which we
personally do live then you have to
accept a couple things one is that not
all the worlds count equally okay there
is an amplitude there's a wave function
squared which plays the role of how many
copies there are right that's why you
get the borne rule when you say I'm
going to have a probability I'm going to
predict the outcome of a Quantum
measurement probabilistically I'm going
to say it's 2/3 for this 1/3 for that in
many worlds both outcomes actually come
true so why in the world would you say
there's a probability of 2/3 versus 1/3
the answer is that the 2/3 Branch counts
more in a very quantifiable way and if
you accept that then these branches on
which you live forever count enormously
tiny amounts like infinitesimally almost
immeasurably tiny amounts it's not
something that should affect your
everyday life in any way the prospect of
this living forever and as I've said you
know before many times including by the
way in my new wri course on the many
worlds of quantum
mechanics when we think about why it
would be bad to die if you think that
way you're thinking about it now there
is some
value right now into thinking that I'm
not going to die within the next couple
of minutes okay so even in a classical
Universe where there's only one world
there's not many worlds or anything like
that you still want to live a long time
even though once you're dead you're not
going to care about it the reason to be
upset about the prospect of death which
is a perfectly legitimate reaction to
have is not because once you're dead you
will be sad that was never the idea
the prospect of dying in the future is
upsetting to me now and so the same
thing is true with Quantum immortality
the idea that there is a branch of the
wave function or a version of me will
continue forever is completely swamped
by the fact that on most branches of the
wave function the overwhelming majority
of them there is no version of me that
is continuing forever so I feel about
that in exactly the same way that I
would feel about living in a single
Universe where I had a finite lifespan
and of course the other thing to keep in
mind is that these different versions of
you are not all you they are your
descendence in time you have to update
what you mean by personal identity if
you're going to accept many worlds so
it's cold comfort to think there's other
people who share a common past with you
that are going to live forever but
you're not so I think that there's no
Solace to be found in the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics if
what we want is to live forever now
that's a little bit of science I wanted
to get out of the way not because it's
really what I care about in this uh
brief podcast but because people will be
thinking about it once they hear it's me
talking and once they hear immortality
in the title they want to hear about the
quantum immortality thing that's my take
on it I want to actually be a little bit
more down to earth here um first let's
let's ask whether or not in the real
world if there was actual immortality
not just Quantum immortality if there
was a feasible chance that I could live
on a lot of branches of the wave
function for effectively
forever what would that be like and for
that matter would it be good so there
was one person I'm I'm very sorry I
forget who it was there was a person at
the Santa Fe Workshop who had the very
very good idea of taking a poll of the
people in the room and remember the
people in the room are selected to be in
some way interested in the topic of
immortality one way or the other I mean
they didn't volunteer they were asked
and they said okay I'll go so they were
chosen as people who might have thoughts
about immortality let's put it that way
and the poll question was very simple if
you could live for 10,000 years and
let's say that you are as healthy for
all those 10,000 years as you ever have
been okay so you don't just decline in
capabilities for all those Millennia
ahead of you would you want to would you
want to live for 10,000 years uh sizable
major majority of the room said no they
would not want to live for 10,000 years
that's too long I was one of the
minority there I absolutely voted to
live for 10,000 years I mean I am
absolutely impressed by the number of
things that I want to do in life that I
don't have time to do right so the idea
of 10,000 years to kind of relax and get
it all done that's very very appealing
to me the specific number 10,000 years
is very hard to judge if you think very
roughly speaking that we all live for on
average order of magnitude for one
century for 100 years that's you know
multiplying the average human lifespan
by 100 it's very hard to judge whether
you would go a little bit crazy and if
you look into literature which people uh
at the workshop were absolutely
interested in doing it is very
interesting how many cautionary tales
there are about immortality there's a
story by Jorge Luis bores who we talked
recently uh about on the podcast with
William eggington he wrote a story
called The Immortals there it is and I'm
not going to spoil it for you it's a
short story you can find it on the
internet very easily but suffice it to
say there are characters in the story
who are Immortal and they're not living
very enjoyable lives in fact they're
called
trites it's sort of for various reasons
right like you run out of things to be
interested in and even more you're not
in a hurry right if there's some
experience you want to have according to
bores but you're going to live forever
what's your motivation really to get it
done anytime soon right it'll it'll come
around once in a while eventually so I
think that's quite plausible that you
would actually feel that way if you were
literally going to live forever my
favorite example of this kind of story
which I'm sure I mentioned on the
podcast before but I can't remember when
uh is Julian Barnes in his book The
History of the World in 10 and a half
chapters the last chapter is called the
dream and it's a guy dies and he goes to
heaven so he can be immortal so there's
the gimmick in Julian barnes's version
of Heaven is you get anything you want
and you can live forever but we're not
going to tell you what you want you have
to invent what you want so I like that
version of it because it faces the
reality of our finitude right like time
is
infinite possibility is infinite but our
imaginations or maybe to be more fair
our desires or our interests are finite
we human beings are finite so you're
placed in a situation in heaven where
you get anything you want and the
particular guy we're looking at here is
not the most imaginative person in the
world in the context of the Julian
Barnes story uh it's in a novel history
of the world in 10 and a half chapters
but the novel consists of a series of
stories that are more or less unrelated
so basically he's a middle class English
bloke and he wants to you know have
breakfast foods for dinner every day and
have sex with a lot of beautiful women
and meet all of his celebrity uh
favorite celebrities and then he wants
to play golf every day and get holes in
one and if you have enough time and you
can do anything you want then you can do
all those things right and at some point
given that you are finite and I think
that this is just very very telling at
some point you run out of things to be
interested in this is a a much broader
lesson in my mind we sometimes talk
about eternity or infinity or
immortality as human beings we don't
really think about it deeply enough we
kind of tend to conflate immortality
with longevity with big numbers with
infinite numbers right but they're not
really the same thing and we human
beings at least at the moment at least
in the kind of form that human beings
are known to have are finite and that
includes our desires and our hopes and
our ability to imagine so our hero our
protagonist in the Julian Barnes story
uh eventually asks his Guardian Angel he
says like is there any option to um no
longer persist to basically die right to
stop being here in heaven and the angel
says yes that is absolutely an option
that that you can take and he says wow
that's that's kind of amazing has anyone
ever taken this option like to give up
on Heaven and the angel says everyone
takes the option that's what's going to
happen says Julian barens we are not
going to want to actually be immortal
and I don't know though about 10,000
years that's the interesting question
how long would you want to live I
completely agree that you would not want
to live for Infinity years but I think
10,000 years years you might want to
live finally of course on the good place
the TV show that was recently quite
popular I encourage everyone to watch
the good place it was a great show and
at the end of the show they came to a
similar conclusion again I'm not going
to spoil I kind of spoiled the Julian
Barn story but I'll let you watch the
good place they had to confront exactly
the same kind of question and they did
it in a very interesting way so I I
think that again there's a difference
between living forever and living for
10,000 years I don't want to live
forever but I do I personally do want to
live for 10,000 years I'm interested in
what mindscape listeners might think
about this by the way one of the people
who was at the workshop was Ted Chang
who is a science fiction writer
excellent writer uh wrote a lot of good
stories including ones on which movies
were based like arrival for example uh
can highly recommend his books and he's
actually spending time now at SFI
hanging out with the Santa Fe people and
he gave a little talk where he he made
an impassion plea for why immortality
would be bad but it was communally based
it was not individually based so it
wasn't that you would get bored it was
kind of more along the bores line he was
saying that society would sort of
stagnate we would fall into a rut there
is something to be said there is a
evolutionary reason why and not just
biological evolution but social
Evolution why people need to die because
people get stuck people are very
successful in one mode or another and
they're going to keep trying that and
new ideas Bubble Up from younger people
and if you have immortality or effective
immortality in your Society there are no
younger people you got to say look sorry
we cannot have kids or anything like
that or we'll just exponentially grow in
numbers that would be bad so no more
kids no more ideas no more young people
no more youth with their energy and so
forth there is a footnote here about
youthful energy which I think I
personally think youthful energy is
really really important and there's a
whole political social kind of
commentary to have that I'm not going to
go into right now about the weirdness
with which certain culture War battles
are fought on the grounds of what the
kids in the universities and the
colleges these days are doing I think
that kids in universities and colleges
they're not kids anymore they're they're
grown-ups by the time they were in
University but they still have that
energy that drive that desire to make a
difference in the
world sometimes that's going to lead
them to go too far to be extreme to go A
Step Beyond where they should go and by
all means they should be told don't go
there but we still need to let them make
those mistakes we need to encourage that
youthful energy and that willingness to
change the world okay that little
footnote is now gone I disagreed with
Ted about um falling into a rut a little
bit I mean I think there are ways to you
know it's kind of a silly argument
because we're not going to be immortal
or anything like that I think that there
would be ways to keep Society
interesting and new and novel even
without actual new young people being
created there could still be new ideas
that are being created but I get it I
get the argument and I think it's very
valid so I think that the the point of
this little digression this long
digression is that it's not obvious that
immortality is a good thing we need to
sit and think about whether we want it
as well as what I'm going to eventually
get to here the point of this little
podcast is can we possibly get it but
one final thing before we get there is
that there's different kinds of
immortality of course right Ernest
Hemingway famously said that everyone
dies twice when they stop breathing and
the last time anyone ever thinks about
them or says their name sometimes this
quote is attributed to Banky but Banky
was clearly quoting Hemingway here you
can have a legacy right you can
physically be dead but you can live on
in the impact that you've had on the
world it reminds me there was a recent
ask me anything question uh by Mark with
no l name uh which which asked whether
or not I cared how long I will be
remembered right so there's two
different ways in which we're going to
die we're going to die because we liter
physically die and then because everyone
forgets us and I think that you know
this is one of the many ways that you
can emphasize the Stark reality of the
end of our lives right it's not just
that you stop existing but all sorts of
things associated with you come to an
end if you like to read books there is a
last book you will read There is a last
time you will see the person you fall in
love with there is a last meal that you
will have there's a last good idea that
you will have and then after you're dead
there's a last time someone thinks about
you a last time someone says your name
out loud last time someone reads about
you in a book or anything like that
these are all
implications of the finitude of human
life of course Hemingway is trying to
say some people last longer than others
some people they're going to keep
reading my books whoever who he was
talking to I'm not sure about that but
my answer for the AMA question was I
don't really care
about that I'm I'm very much about the
time that I have where I'm conscious
here on Earth living my life I'm much
less interested in what's going on after
I am dead in fact there was a wonderful
little intervention by Scott small who
was another person at the workshop he
was a neuroscientist and he mentioned
the idea of a ceremony of forgetting
probably in the context of Ceremonies of
atonement you know forgetting our sins
forgetting the bad things that we've
done but the more general idea of
letting things go into into the past and
I think this is sympathetic with what
Ted Chang was saying if you take
mortality seriously if you don't
struggle against the inevitable passing
of ourselves and our memories then
rather than doing that let's honor it
let's say okay we remembered you for a
long time we're not going to think about
you anymore we're going to honor your
memory by forgetting by moving on
because life continues for the people
who still are are still around I thought
that was very touching probably
difficult to pull off in practice but it
it does raise the question of what can
we do in practice right okay so we've
been talking about whether or not
immortality would be good or not how to
think about the implications of it Etc
but it doesn't matter if you can't do it
right if then it's then we're just sort
of wasting our time and telling each
other's stories again maybe that maybe
it matters in the sense that I mentioned
earlier that we help our elves
conceptualize the finite life we have
and that's fine but is it just that kind
of thought experiment usefulness or is
there some realistic prospect that we
could live forever by the way I do like
to emphasize that as far as I can tell
the idea of extending Our Lives much
longer than they currently exist is very
realistic not necessarily within my
lifetime but you know this is a biology
problem not a physics problem there's no
problem as far as the laws of physics
are concerned with repairing yourself as
a biological organism it's not built
into what our uh biological capacities
actually are but that's okay we can
change them right that's what medicine
and biology are all about you know one
of the first podcasts I did or at least
you know in the first couple months was
with Colleen Murphy who is a researcher
at Princeton and I was happy to see she
just has a new book out called how we
Aid
so I strongly encourage you if you're
interested in this life extension
question read what Colleen says she's
not a crazy person she's actually very
serious scientist and she will give you
both what is plausible and what we
cannot do based on actual experiments
that have been done but if you're asking
you know a thousand years from now how
long can we extend our lives for we have
no idea and the answer might very well
be effectively forever as far as I know
I think it's you know it's important
given what we were talking about last
week with Adam Frank and aliens and so
forth it's important to recognize that
if you are contemplating Interstellar
travel and going ah it's not realistic
really realistic it will take thousands
of years you know maybe our lifespan is
tens of thousands of years or millions
of years so maybe that becomes totally
realistic but even that is very
different than infinity years it's not
quite Immortal right so let's actually
think and now I can talk about the
science that I tried to bring to the
workshop on the cosmology and physics
side of things right let's be very very
honest and ask would it be in principle
possible to live forever in some
recognizable way given that we human
beings are biological organisms as I
said on a recent podcast we are Quasi
homeostatic non-equilibrium systems
embedded in entropy gradient
and the fact that the entropy of the
universe is increasing is crucially
important to life right life on Earth in
particular is possible because the sun
is a hot spot in an otherwise cold Sky
that's a reflection of the fact that we
are very very far from thermal
equilibrium we are non-equilibrium
processes if you took all of the
information contained in me and you
wrote it in a book and then you know put
the book on the shelf that book would
not be me right there's nothing
happening there's no time Evolution
there's no development there's no
increase in memory or experience or
anything like that to be alive to be
human to be a living organism in the way
that we think about it it is necessary
for time to pass and for you to
accumulate memories and experiences and
knowledge as well as making predictions
about the future and that is all very
strongly based on the Arrow of time and
the arrow of time as you all know from
the SC the podcast comes about because
our universe used to have very low
entropy entropy thought of as a way of
counting how many micro States look a
certain way in the macroscopic
configuration of the universe our early
Universe was hot dense smooth rapidly
expanding turns out that's a very very
tiny number of micro States look that
way compared to the number of states of
the universe that look the way that our
universe looks today and in in turn that
the number of states that look like the
universe today is very very small
compared to how many how we could look
that is to say We are continuing to
approach thermal equilibrium the actual
thing that is happening is the universe
expands from a hot dense state it cools
off gravity pulls things together we
make some black holes black holes have
huge amounts of entropy we also make
galaxies and planets and stars as well
as life and so forth and eventually it
all goes away that's the big lesson that
I that I have for you here not
necessarily A Cheerful one but all of
that churning interestingness and
complexity in the current universe will
eventually disappear Stars will burn
their fuel it's going to take a long
time okay so the universe today is again
order of magnitude 10 to the 10 years
old the last star will probably Peter
out around 10 to the 15 years from now
so that's plenty of time to do lots of
interesting things but eventually those
stars are going to die they'll fall into
black holes the black holes will
evaporate and the evaporation products
will scatter Across the Universe we
discovered back in 1998 that our
universe is not only expanding but
accelerating we attribute that to vacuum
energy to the cosmological constant to
the energy of empty space and there's
going to be nothing but empty space left
if you go far enough into the future all
all the black holes will evaporate into
photons and things like that those
photons will be stretched by the
expansion of the universe into essential
non-existence for all intents and
purposes that's the high entropy state
of the future universe that's thermal
equilibrium in fact uh I I'm sure I
mentioned this one before also but one
of my favorite papers was with Aiden
Chatwin Davis we wrote a paper that
related this particular feature of the
universe in the presence of a
cosmological constant or a non-zero
vacuum energy the universe empties out
and becomes smooth and featureless we
related that to thermal equilibrium
right to the thermodynamic tendency of
entropy to increase in a box of gas
until you reach equilibrium and then it
just stays at that constant amount we
wrote a very fun paper that said that
you can actually prove what is called
The Cosmic Noir theorem the cosmic no
hair theorem originally coming from Bob
Wald show showed that if you have a
universe with a positive cosmological
constant that does not recollapse then
eventually just empties out you get
nothing but empty space de space is the
technical term and so that's a result in
general relativity and what Aiden and I
did is not use general relativity so we
did not use Einstein's equation of
general relativity instead we used a
definition of
entropy that is applicable to a
situation where you have both gravity so
there's entropy in the gravitational
field but also you have matter you have
stuff you have photons and things like
that so there's both matter entropy and
gravitational entropy this definition
was written down by I was amused to
remember two former mindscape guests
rapael buso and Netta anglehart they
collaborated on a paper together and so
they wrote down this definition of
entropy that applies in cosmological
situations and what Aiden and I did is
to say okay if this particular
definition of entropy simply Rises for a
while then asmp tootes to a constant
finite
value what does that imply about the
expansion of the universe and we proved
that it implies that you approach toter
space just like the cosmic Noir theorem
you approach an empty Universe with uh
exponentially growing expansion Etc that
is the highest entropy State the
universe can be in empty space nothing
going on so what that means is back to
reality now the fact that we're not
there the fact that we're not in empty
space the fact that we are lower entropy
than that allows life to exist the
initial low entropy of the universe is a
resource that we are using up we are
increasing the entropy of the universe
approaching that final empty thermal
equilibrium State and we have a finite
amount of that resource to use we need
low entropy energy technically you might
call it free energy in the technical
physics term but it's not like energy
for free it's energy that is available
to do useful things we use free energy
to metabolize to act to think to live
right that's the usefulness of having
the sun there as a hot spot in a cold
sky so we need that in order for life to
exist you see how this is relevant to
the question of
immortality now as I've often talked
about often uh one way of thinking about
this Universal process is that
complexity comes into existence and then
evaporates away there is a simple
initial State for the universe there is
a simple final State for the universe
complexity comes in the middle and
that's where we are right now so people
when I say that always want to know you
know are we exactly at the top of the
complexity curve or are we slightly past
it or before it or what and we don't
know I don't know a good way to quantify
that I I do have one little piece of
information that maybe is relevant that
I shared with everyone at Santa Fe one
thing that you can actually calculate is
the rate of star formation in the
universe so how many stars and when I
say in the universe I mean in our
observable universe so the total amount
of stuff is finite uh we're looking at
some co-moving volume with a certain
number of atoms inside and asking how
many stars are produced and you know you
can look out there in galaxies and star
forming regions there's plenty of Stars
being produced but then you do it
carefully and you learn that we are past
the era of peak star formation in our
universe star formation peaked around
four or five billion years after the big
bang and now we are 15 or 14 billion
years after the big bang star formation
rates have been declining for almost 10
billion years so that does not mean that
complexity is declining but it means
that that kind of
the particular kind of complexity
definitely is not increasing over time
right like all the stars most of the
stars that have ever been formed in the
history of our universe have that will
ever be formed have already been formed
this is a reminder and I'm not saying
this I want it to be true this is just
what science is telling us the
interesting part of the life of our
universe is
finite you know you can judge what
exactly the number is in different ways
but it's not going to last forever the
universe started simple complexity comes
into existence and flourishes for a
while but that while is finite we will
eventually evaporate dissolve into the
surrounding thermal equilibrium that is
the sad science message that I had to
bring to the folks at Santa Fe we can
even quantify this a little bit those of
you who are physicists out there might
know there's a famous paper by Freeman
Dyson from back in 1979 Freeman Dyson
famous physicist wrote a paper called
time Without End physics and biology in
an open Universe I think this paper is
famous anyway it was clearly not famous
enough because no one else at the
workshop had heard about it besides me
but what Dyson was saying is that let's
imagine so he's 1979 he's writing this
right so they didn't know a lot about
the future history of the universe maybe
will recollapse maybe will expand
forever and so forth certainly the idea
of the cosmological constant any Eternal
acceleration was known in principle but
was not considered a leading candidate
so people didn't pay a lot of
attention so Dyson says what if the
universe is open that is to say he's
imagining that the total amount of
matter in the universe is not enough to
cause the universe to stop expanding and
then recollapse so the universe will
last forever so that's the kind of
universe in which you might say well
maybe there's a hope for being Immortal
right the universe lasts forever but
also it's expanding again not thinking
about vacuum energy or the cosmological
constant but the temperature is going
down the density of matter is going down
so you might worry that you know we run
out of energy run out of stuff and
Dyson's Insight his argument was you
could live forever in an open Universe
because if you think that it takes a
certain amount of energy to have a
thought well what you can do is just
have thoughts that take less L and less
energy but take more and more time so
basically Dyson argues there's a
competition if you allow yourself to
count as a thought you know a certain
amount of energy expended but you give
yourself more and more time for it to
happen do what is the sum that you do do
you get to fit an infinite number of
thoughts into the universe into this
infinitely old universe and he says the
answer is yes the universe is getting
less and less dense colder and colder
and colder but you can still fit an
infinite number of thoughts into it very
interesting and you might think at first
that adding a cosmological constant to
this question doesn't change it very
much it's still an open Universe it's
still cooling off but not that much
differently than it would an ordinary
open universe but there is a physics
difference that actually matters because
as I said the state that we approach is
not manowski space which would be empty
space with nothing in it at all but it
is deci space space empty space with a
cosmal constant in it and then our
observable universe has an upper limit
on its entropy so the observable
universe starts with a very small
entropy and then increases but only to a
finite amount that's kind of a important
thing that's a very different situation
than what Dyson had considered and I I
looked a little bit for you know was
there anyone talking about this
important impact on Dyson's art argument
but I couldn't find any probably it's
out there somewhere I'm probably not
completely original on what I'm about to
say but the entropy of our observable
universe has an upper bound which we
think is about 10 to 122 the universe
will expand and thermalize equilibrate
to that kind of state where there's a
finite entropy around us what that means
is there is an upper limit on life
because that thinking you know Dyson was
worried about energy not about entropy
so he imagined thinking you know more
and more slowly using up less and less
energy but computation the kind of
computation that is relevant to life and
thinking increases the entropy of the
universe uh roughly speaking every bit
of information that is processed
increases the entropy of the universe by
one okay now you can argue about this
there's details there are reversible
computations and things like that but
the fact is that the kind of
computations that are relevant to
thinking remembering predicting the
future stuff like that do generate
entropy they increase the entropy of the
universe around you so if thinking and
therefore if living and thinking
increase the entropy of the universe and
there's an upper limit to the entropy of
the universe then guess what there's an
upper limit on how much life there can
be in the future history of our universe
so so how much life can you fit into the
rest of the universe and here this is
just you know my backof the envelope
calculation again someone probably did
this more carefully but here's what I
came up with if you ask about the total
entropy production of a single human
lifetime you can actually look up the
numbers uh human beings increase the
entropy of the universe around them by
about 10 to the 23 bits per second I
don't know where that number comes from
it's mostly the infrared radiation that
we're giving off okay
uh and that's safely above the number of
computations that we're doing the number
of computations in a human brain is
roughly 10 to the 20 bits per second and
I said that every computation increases
the entropy by one so the fact that the
computation rate is 10 20 bits per
second the entropy production is 10 23
bits per second is perfectly consistent
it's just saying that most of our entry
production does not come from thinking
which is probably quite real istic right
like we're also just sweating and and uh
radiating out into the universe just by
maintaining our temperature and things
like that so okay let's take the total
entropy production of a human being and
let's multiply it by a century right for
the typical human lifetime and let's get
10 to the 29 as the number of bits of
entropy generated in a typical human
lifetime call that a human life
equivalent 10 to the 29 bits per
lifetime history to date if you just
count the number of human beings who
have existed is about 10 to the 11 human
life equivalents actually actual human
lives as a matter of fact in that case
but we're imagining that maybe in the
future it's not actual human lives it's
you know in The Matrix or something like
that or some kind of collective
intelligence who knows we're just
talking about the entropy production in
a typical human lifespan now projecting
it into however that might be in
instantiated into the future well if you
have uh the Earth lasting for a long
time before the sun expands right like
let's be down to earth here let's take
the number of humans now about 10 to the
10 humans on the Earth today and let's
imagine that we exist just here on Earth
we don't colonize the sky okay and we
last until the sun blows up then that's
about 10 to the e8th centuries 10 to the
10 humans right now so that's 10 to the
human life equivalents so in other words
we've had 10 to the 11 human life
equivalents so far in history another 10
to the 18 to go so we're nowhere near
everything that could be accomplished
just here on Earth as long as we don't
do something dumb like ruining the Earth
while we're here on it that's still
nothing compared to what happens if we
do colonize the Stars if we go out into
the sky uh fill the Milky Way galaxies
10 to the 11 planets for the rest of the
lifetime of the stars in our galaxy we
get up to 10 to the 34 human life
equivalents so this is how many human
life equivalents could be experienced by
life forms in our Milky Way galaxy
between now and when the last star dies
10 to the 15 years from now 10 to the 34
way bigger than the 10 to the 11 that
have actually existed here on Earth and
finally just to you know blow our minds
a little bit I said that there's an
upper bound on the total amount of
entropy we can fit in the universe 10 to
the
122 how many human life equivalents does
that count as well if it's 10 29 bits
per lifespan of a human being that's 10
the 93 human life equivalents that we
can fit into the universe that's a very
very large number 10 to the 93 so if we
did
nothing but harness all of the resources
in the observable universe and put them
to the task of thinking of acting like
human beings whatever that means to
think and learn and love and write
poetry and whatever you could do that
for 10 to the 93 human life equivalents
which it's not realistic that but that's
the upper bound we're not trying to be
realistic and say that's what would
happen that is the maximum number you
can contemplate and 10 the 93 human life
equivalence is a very big number but it
is finite that's the final lesson here
the final lesson here is given that our
universe is moving toward thermal
equilibrium that it is cooling off and
getting smoother and getting eventually
kind of bland and featureless and going
toward a situation where life itself
cannot exist it doesn't matter how
clever you are it doesn't matter how you
Marshall the resources around you to
sort of say well I'm going to like build
a bunker I'm going to pack enough food
to last longer than the universe etc etc
you can't do it unless you die unless
you literally don't exist as long as you
are still existing like a human being
still having thoughts still increasing
the entropy of the universe there is an
upper bound to doing that okay it's a
bound that is very very far away
completely irrelevant to our current
existence here on Earth but it is there
so the bad news from cosmology is
immortality of human beings or even of
the human race is not a foreseeable
Prospect you can still live a long time
don't get me wrong but true immortality
is beyond our grasp there's one little
footnote here with which I will close
this whole uh holiday reflection holiday
message which is okay is it possible the
last loophole maybe is maybe we human
beings will just equilibrate into the
universe around us but could the
universe be immortal Could It Last
Forever uh yeah that's absolutely
possible it's absolutely possible for
the universe to last forever the
conventional picture is that we just of
course expand from The Big Bang from the
hot Den State our entropy increases
toward the future and eventually we hit
to sitter space and then nothing ever
happens but nothing ever happens for an
infinite amount of time so that is
absolutely a kind of immortality right
but if you think about why the early
Universe had low entropy in the first
place that's a big mystery that we don't
have a good answer to uh as most
listeners know I wrote a paper back
almost 20 years ago now with Jennifer
Chen uh that that proposed a large scale
model of the universe large scale
cosmological scenario in which most of
space and time is precisely local
thermal equilibrium de space empty space
nothing there nothing nothing going on
but if we add to that the possibility
that there can be a Quantum fluctuation
that creates a little baby Universe in
some local region of space even if the
rate at which such fluctuations happen
is very very very small you have
Infinity years to Wait So eventually
you'll get lots of baby universes and
they will inside them actually typically
a baby universe will just recollapse
right away but if conditions are just
right it can expand and inflate and have
its own Arrow of time it can expand and
cool and have a initially low entropy
just in the baby Universe before it
expands and thermal thermal equilibrium
eventually happens and there's a
temporary period where life can exist in
that baby Universe before it eventually
goes back to its quiescent empty State
and in this scenario there will be an
infinite number of of those baby
universes in which that happens so I
kind of like this scenario for I like it
because it helps explain why the early
Universe had low entropy but I like its
implications for immortality and this is
you know that the happy conclusion I
came to when I was thinking about what
to say at the Santa Fe
Workshop in this scenario the universe
lasts
forever but most of it is dead right
most of it is empty space nothing going
on there are brief little
fluctuations where complex systems
including living creatures can come into
existence in the baby universes and in
their
aftermaths but that makes that's there's
a good news bad news situation here the
good news is that uh that will happen
forever so there will always be future
beings in our future light go in the
future of our universe there will be
thought there will be love there will be
caring and meaningfulness and purpose at
least temporarily in regions of space
and time that will exist in the future
of our universe that's the good news the
other news which I'm not going to
necessarily call good or bad is that no
information is passed from Universe to
Universe the process of the quantum
fluctuation that makes the baby universe
doesn't rely or depend or care about
what came before it is a completely um
it's it's blind to what the conditions
of the universe were that created it so
whatever universe is created and again
our universe might very well be one of
these universes that came about by this
mechanism it doesn't know what happened
before we can hypothesize about it we
could that's what we're doing right now
we can think about it we can say uh the
existence of a pre-existing universe is
the best way of making sense of the
universe we see but we can't know we
can't talk to them we can't commun
communicate with them nor can they
communicate with us so in some sense
this kind of cosmological scenario is
the ultimate ceremony of forgetting it
is the ultimate way that the universe
renews itself rejuvenates Itself by
forcing us not to stick around in a way
that Ted Chang would be happy about we
can't impose our thoughts and
preferences and so forth on our far far
far future
life forms because they can't possibly
know about us we have forgotten they
have forgotten us we have forgotten
whoever came before us and maybe this is
the universe's way of saying that's how
it should be you shouldn't have the
baggage of an infinite past nor should
you be able to put constraints on the
infinite future that's a good way for
the universe to keep going forever while
still maintaining some freshness about
the whole
situation that's the holiday message for
this year I hope that you had a good
2023 um nothing's happening next week
for mindscape so we'll see you in
January have a great holiday take
[Music]
care
w